c'est vrai qu'encore aujourd'hui il ya
des gens qui viennent me voir et qui me
disent c'est grâce à toi que j'ai dit ça
à telle personne
enfin c'est ce que j'aime dans le cinéma
c'est à dire que des fois quand tu sors
d'une salle de ciné au delà de
l'expérience ça peut te donne envie de
pardonner ça peut être donner envie
d'aider mais ça peut et c'est vrai que
la vida delsahut cet impact là j'avais
fait quelques trucs amont mais c'est
vrai que voilà je continue à aller à
l'école et pour moi c'était je
connaissais au cinéma c'était un peu du
hasard c'est un casting qui a été très
long qui a duré six mois c'était le
moment où j'ai voulu lâcher l'école où
j'ai lâché ma ma scolarité et c'est vrai
que ça a changé ma vie parce que voilà
c'est un réalisateur qui m'a prise alors
que j'avais pas forcément beaucoup
d'expérience pour un premier rôle et
pour incarner cette grande histoire
d'amour entre moi et léa seydoux et puis
ça a changé ma vie puisque ça ça m'a
vraiment appris une vision du cinéma où
il n'ya pas de marques au sol pas de
limitation de temps pâle imitation de
texte ou c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement dans dans le partage dans
l'endurance dans la dévotion du coup ça
m'a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
appris énormément donné on va pas se
mentir
avant j'étais vraiment sale on dit tu
peux sortir la photo s'il te plaît
ouais c'est ça qui m'a appris aussi
qu'il fallait que je vois la nudité à ce
moment là comme un déguisement mais
j'étais aussi beaucoup plus insouciants
quoi j'étais plus libres j'étais plus
jeune et après c'est vrai que ça a été
entaché par toute une polémique moi
aujourd'hui dans mon coeur je n'en garde
que des bons souvenirs
après je trouvais ça important si voilà
certaines personnes avaient besoin de
s'exprimer et cetera je trouvais ça st
c'est vrai que c'est venu tout entachée
il y avait des choses forcément injuste
comme quand les choses elle déborde et
que c'est repris par intel les mots d'un
tel lot j'ai trouvé ça dommage que ça
laisse pas entre nous mais
personnellement je regrette rien c'est
plus important choix je vais à los
angeles à trappes à un prix pour la vida
d'elle et je suis hyper stressé parce
que je dois là une cérémonie recevant un
prix je crois que c est les world bouger
plus et je sais dicaprio en plus qu'ils
donnent leur maître ou je sais pas quoi
bon bref je suis super stressé parce que
c'est con amérique il ya des choses
qu'on peut pas dire est en fait dans la
voiture et à un agent qui m'appellent et
qui me dit ouais je ne peux ni votre
rencontre et je rentre à l'hôtel je me
change me dis je vais pas du tout qu'ils
me voient en grandes robes etc qui se
disent mais qu'est ce qu'elle fait
je mets un petit jogging et tout ce que
j'étais très maquillée je descends je
suis un peu stressée je me dis shon
pence quand même quelqu'un j'ai grandi
avec son cinéma pour moi c'est un
monstre d'acteur c'est quelqu'un que
j'estime énormément mais qui est ce qui
me veut et donc je fume cigarette là
j'entends haye et je lève la tête
pendant j'avoue je lève par la tétine et
pas immense mais je joue je les mangas
je le vois et là il me propose son
scénario et c'est vrai que j'avais trop
du mal à y croire tellement j'étais
heureuse ça m'a beaucoup appris et puis
ça m'a pris c'était une expérience
américaine aussi ou d'un coup bas tout
et tout est anticipée du coût cantharide
poum et toute la lumière les 450
figurants le tout et du coup tu étais tu
étais tu as le temps de travail est
vraiment en fait quand arrive d'être
libre mais la première journée il y
avait javier bardem à main gauche
charlize theron à ma droite sean penn en
face de moi je me suis dit c'est une
blague
[Musique]
sur le tournage d perdu mon c'est vrai
que donc jouer une jeune femme qui est
condamnée donc coupable et du coup je
suis à la fleury mérogis pour faire des
cours d'un pro donc au début c'était un
peu vertigineux dans le sens où je n'ai
absolument pas la prétention de savoir
faire des cours ni dans cotisations du
théâtre et puis je me suis très vite
rendu compte qu'il fallait s'adapter aux
besoins de des femmes qui étaient là-bas
en fait ça à rien de venir avec des
théories ou une morale ou un programme
s'était dit revoir la façon qu'ils
parlent quelle langue qui a envie de
faire quoi et venant partagent un truc
donc au début on a commencé avec des
caisses des jingles pub des loups garous
pour les mettre tous en confiance et
pour qu'on arrive à se réunir et après
on a beaucoup beaucoup parlé à dire à
quel film pas trop toucher quelle scène
tu aimerais remixé et c'est vrai que
c'était quand même une grande leçon de
cinéma d'arriver à voir des gens sans
ego qui arrivait à être extrêmement vrai
dans une situation qui leur étaient pas
forcément arriver mais qu'ils étaient
incapables de tricher en fait donc
c'était une grande leçon d'humanité et
c'est vrai que moi d'avoir passé tous
ces mois fleuri ça m'a appris que pour
moi ce qui compte le plus c'est l'humain
en fait c'est tout